ihr könnt euch schon bei dem dreizehnten
lebensjahr ist das wichtig dass ihr
schon so lange zusammen das macht
ich denke schon ich glaube das macht
einen großteil dessen aus was am ende
rauskommt weil wir einfach sehr
eingespielt sind und natürlich sind wir
zwei verschiedene menschen aber so ich
sag mal was die musik angeht und die
gemeinsame vision hat sich das einfach
schon sehr lange gemeinsam entwickelt
naja und genetik ist unsere gemeinsame
vision und die da dient die musik die
wir machen und das lebt natürlich schon
sehr lange nebeneinander her und einer
hat vom anderen gelernt und lernt immer
noch vom anderen und deswegen würde ich
schon sagen dass so diese kombination
dieses vertrauen was zwischen uns
besteht und auch die die ja die
interessen und das das gemeinsame uhr
sozusagen die gemeinsame vorliebe für
eine gewisse klangfarbe und so dass die
natürlich ausgeprägter ist als bei
leuten die sich vielleicht erst kurze
zeit kennen aber das kann natürlich auch
wie die faust aufs auge passen und nach
einem jahr machen uns schon gute musik
zusammen das kann natürlich auch ganz
schnell gehen
aber bei uns ist eben sehr organische
struktur bestimmt mucke die man sich
anhören können die man nach außen geben
konnte bestimmt fünf sechs sieben jahre
also natürlich haben wir unsere sachen
auch schon früher gefeiert so den ersten
track denn wir aufgenommen haben haben
wir schon gedacht wir sind die
krassesten von allen natürlich aber und
aber natürlich im nachhinein ist man
schlauer und merkt an ok das war schon
ziemlich trotz der wir da gemacht haben
aber so ist das so man fängt an und das
einer der wichtigsten regeln überhaupt
im leben und das gilt für die musik
genauso wie für alle anderen
lebensbereiche ist dran bleiben muss
einfach dranbleiben und weiter machen
es gibt natürlich schon ein oder anderen
der nicht peilt dass er vielleicht
aufhören sollte lieber das kann
natürlich auch passieren dass man sich
verrennt aber wenn man mit viel
leidenschaft an etwas dran geht und
bereit ist zu investieren zu lernen zu
arbeiten fleißig zu sein und irgendwann
wird man besser im regelfall auch
wirklich einige jahre
auch ein comedian der brauch sieben
jahre nach ich glaube auch in der
wirtschaft und unternehmen aufbaus dann
ist so die halbwertszeit bis man zum
ersten mal rentabel wird drei bis fünf
jahre ist ganz normal also die selten
also den seltensten fällen hat man eine
idee und ist über nacht millionär siehe
apple wie lange haben sie gebraucht um
durchzubrechen sie haben am anfang ein
riesenerfolg genau herunter gekracht und
dann ja aber du siehst du das ist halt
so dass sind erfolgsgeschichten sind nie
nur straight
was für ein verhältnis habt ihr was seid
ihr seid der kollegen seit der freunde
seit der brüder wie würdet ihr das wird
wie würdet ihr werfen nennen oder was
gehört dazu eine gute musiker beziehung
zu haben
also ich würde sagen dass wir
irgendetwas zwischen all dem sind so
also wir haben eine sehr enge
menschliche beziehung zueinander
maximales vertrauen da wenn du willst
kannst du das als als bruderschaft
bezeichnen auf jeden fall warum nicht
mehr burger vom ok doch wieder geht mir
sehr offen sagt immer es nicht witzig
und nervt einfach nur ab aber geht schon
also dass eigentlich der kreative bist
du und der nerv nur genau so sehe ich
das
das klärende kind das auf dem boden
stand aber warum seid ihr produkt also
was ist dann ja keine andere kreiert das
wir können uns halt auch einfach sagen
wir können uns halt einfach sagen wenn
wir uns offen sagt dann sage ich mach
mal kopf zu jetzt oder umgekehrt
und dann ist gut an streitet man sich
halt auch kurz das gehört natürlich auch
dazu und dann hofft man sich halt
einfach wieder zusammen so wir haben so
alle großen streit schon hinter uns sage
ich mal was war der größte
das nie aber das war nicht der gleiche
typ für uns interessant ist aber keine
ahnung sollte gab verein würde sich
freuen sich wo man sich um einen
schlecht behandeln erfüllt oder so und
so keine ahnung
jugend geschichten halt einfach wie jede
wie jede junge männer freundschaft junge
freundschaft das halt so durchlebt und
dann ist auch irgendwann wieder gut
dann wird man älter und erwachsen und
kann über die dinge sprechen auf einmal
kann sich schon artikulieren und dann
räumt man die dinge im idealfall halt
aus der welt wenn ihr jetzt sagt ihr
habt fünf sechs sieben jahre war das duo
aus riesa trotz aber sah man nicht so
optimal
wo hat wandert begonnen zu funktionieren
weil das auch in eurer zusammenarbeit
ein besonderer moment wo es irgendwie
klick gemacht hat oder also ich würde
sagen es war so dass wir uns in eine
zeit lang nicht mehr gesehen hatten und
dann haben wir uns nach einem jahr oder
so wieder getroffen und in der
zwischenzeit keine musik zusammen
gemacht und dann komm rennt oder gar
keine musik so jeder hat für sich so
passieren weiter vorsichtig macht man
natürlich die leidenschaft immer da ist
und man hat natürlich immer bock
irgendwie und dann haben wir uns wieder
getroffen und gesagt komm so ich habe
mich weiterentwickelt ich mich auch
lassen wir jetzt was richtig ist machen
was man jetzt versuchen ernsthaft das
ganze zu machen